el precio mundial de los alimentos llegara al máximo histórico en 2008.
La gente estaba sufriendo y luchando,
gobiernos y líderes mundiales
tenían que mostrarnos que prestaban atención
y trabajaban para resolverlo.
El tema es que el 2050 está tan lejos en el futuro
que ni siquiera podemos identificarnos con eso,
y más importante,
si seguimos haciendo lo que estamos haciendo,
va a golpearnos mucho antes que esa fecha.
Creo que debemos plantear una pregunta diferente.
La respuesta a esa pregunta
debe enmarcarse de manera diferente.
Si podemos replantear la vieja narrativa
y reemplazarla por nuevos números
que nos den un cuadro más completo,
números que todo el mundo pueda entender
y con los que pueda identificarse,
entonces podemos evitar la crisis por completo.
Antes yo era comerciante de productos básicos
y una de las cosas que aprendí del comercio
es que cada mercado tiene un punto de inflexión,
el punto en el cual el cambio ocurre tan rápidamente
que afecta al mundo
y las cosas cambian para siempre.
Piensen en la última crisis financiera,
o la crisis de las puntocoms.
Así que aquí está mi preocupación.
Podríamos tener un punto de inflexión
en la alimentación y la agricultura mundial
si el aumento de la demanda
supera la capacidad estructural del sistema agrícola para producir alimentos.
Esto significa que ahí la oferta ya no se mantiene a la altura de la demanda
a pesar de la explosión de precios,
a menos que nos comprometamos a algún tipo de cambio estructural.
En esta época
no se trata de mercados de valores y dinero.
Se trata de personas.
La gente podría morir de hambre y los gobiernos podrían caer.
Esta cuestión de en qué momento la lucha de suministro
para mantenerse al día con la creciente demanda
comenzó a interesarme mientras comerciaba
y se convirtió en una obsesión absoluta.
Pasó del interés a la obsesión
al entender a través de mi investigación lo roto que estaba el sistema
y cómo se tomaban decisiones muy críticas usando muy pocos datos.
En ese momento, decidí no seguir una carrera en Wall Street
y empecé un viaje emprendedor
fundando Gro Intelligence.
En Gro nos centramos en extraer estos datos
y transformarlos en acción,
para empoderar a quienes toman decisiones en todos los niveles.
Pero al hacer este trabajo,
también nos dimos cuenta de que el mundo,
no solo los líderes mundiales,
sino las empresas y los ciudadanos como cada persona en esta sala,
carecían de una guía útil
sobre cómo podemos evitar una crisis mundial de seguridad alimentaria.
Por eso construimos un modelo,
aprovechando los petabytes de datos que teníamos
y abordamos el punto de inflexión.
Nadie sabe que hemos trabajado en este problema
y esta es la primera vez que comparto lo que descubrimos.
Descubrimos que el punto de inflexión es en realidad dentro de una década.
Descubrimos que el mundo
tendrá un déficit de 214 billones de calorías
en 2027.
El mundo no está en condiciones de llenar este vacío.
Verán que
la forma en que abordo esto es diferente de cómo comencé,
y eso es intencional, porque hasta ahora
este problema se ha cuantificado usando masa:
en kilogramos, toneladas, hectogramos,
cualquier unidad de su elección es en masa.
¿Por qué hablamos de alimentos en términos de peso?
Porque es fácil.
Podemos mirar una fotografía y determinar el tonelaje en un barco
usando una calculadora de bolsillo simple.
Podemos pesar camiones, aviones y carros de bueyes.
Pero lo que nos preocupa en los alimentos es el valor nutricional.
No todos los alimentos son iguales,
incluso si pesan lo mismo.
Esto lo aprendí de primera mano
cuando me mudé de Etiopía a EE.UU. para ir a la universidad.
A mi regreso a casa,
mi padre, emocionado de verme,
me saludó preguntándome por qué estaba gorda.
Resulta que comer aproximadamente
la misma cantidad de comida que yo ingería en Etiopía, pero en EE.UU.
había dado cierta plenitud a mi figura.
Esta es la razón por la que debemos preocuparnos por las calorías,
no por la masa.
Son las calorías las que nos sostienen.
Así que 214 billones de calorías es un número muy grande,
y ni siquiera el más comprometido de nosotros
piensa en los cientos de billones de calorías.
Así que déjenme plantear esto de manera diferente.
Una forma alternativa de pensarlo,
es pensarlo en Big Macs.
214 billones de calorías.
Un solo Big Mac tiene 563 calorías.
Eso significa que al mundo le faltarán
379 000 millones Big Macs en 2027.
Eso son más Big Macs de los que McDonald's haya producido jamás.
Pero, ¿cómo llegamos a estos números?
No son inventados.
Este mapa muestra dónde estaba el mundo hace 40 años.
Muestra las brechas netas de calorías en cada país del mundo.
Dicho simplemente,
esto son solo calorías consumidas en ese país
menos las calorías producidas en ese mismo país.
Esto no es una declaración sobre desnutrición u algo así.
Simplemente muestra cuántas calorías se consumen en un solo año
menos las calorías que se producen.
Los países azules son exportadores netos de calorías,
o autosuficientes.
Tienen almacenados en reserva para un día lluvioso.
Los países rojos son importadores netos de calorías.
Cuanto más brillante es el rojo,
más se importa.
Hace 40 años muy pocos países eran exportadores netos de calorías,
se podían contar con una mano.
La mayor parte del continente africano,
Europa, la mayor parte de Asia,
América del Sur excluyendo Argentina,
eran todos importadores netos de calorías.
Y lo sorprendente es que China solía ser autosuficiente en alimentos.
India era un gran importador neto de calorías.
Cuarenta años más tarde, esto es hoy,
pueden ver la transformación drástica que se ha producido en el mundo.
Brasil ha surgido como una potencia agrícola.
Europa es dominante en la agricultura global.
India ha cambiado de rojo a azul.
Se ha convertido en autosuficiente en alimentos.
Y China pasó de ese azul claro
al rojo más brillante que se ve en este mapa.
¿Cómo llegamos aquí? ¿Que pasó?
Así este gráfico muestra India y África.
La línea azul es India, la línea roja es África.
¿Cómo es que dos regiones que comenzaron tan similarmente
en trayectorias similares
emprenden caminos tan diferentes?
India tuvo una revolución verde.
Ningún país africano tuvo una revolución verde.
¿El resultado neto?
India es autosuficiente en alimentos
y en la última década ha estado exportando calorías.
El continente africano ahora importa más de 300 billones de calorías al año.
Luego añadimos China, la línea verde.
¿Recuerdan el cambio del azul al rojo brillante?
¿Qué pasó y cuándo sucedió?
China parecía estar en un camino muy similar a India
hasta el comienzo del siglo XXI,
donde de repente cambió la tendencia.
Una población joven y creciente
combinado con un crecimiento económico significativo
dejó su marca con un big bang
y nadie en los mercados lo vio venir.
Este cambio fue todo para los mercados agrícolas mundiales.
Afortunadamente ahora, América del Sur
empezaba a crecer al mismo tiempo que China ascendía
así, la oferta y la demanda seguían siendo de alguna manera equilibradas.
Así que la pregunta es:
¿A dónde vamos a partir de ahora?
Curiosamente,
no es una historia nueva,
pero esta vez no es solo una historia de China.
Es una continuación de China,
una amplificación de África
y un cambio de paradigma en India.
Para el 2023,
se pronostica que la población de África superará a la de India y China.
En 2023 estas tres regiones combinadas
constituirán más de la mitad de la población mundial.
Este punto de cruce comienza a presentar desafíos realmente interesantes
para la seguridad alimentaria mundial.
Y unos años más tarde estamos muy afectados por esa realidad.
¿Cómo se ve el mundo en 10 años?
Hasta ahora, como he mencionado, India ha sido autosuficiente en alimentos.
La mayoría de los pronosticadores predicen que esto continuará.
No estamos de acuerdo.
India pronto se convertirá en un importador neto de calorías.
Esto será impulsado tanto por el hecho
de que la demanda está creciendo en función del crecimiento de la población
como por el crecimiento económico.
Será impulsado por ambos.
E incluso si tienen suposiciones optimistas
sobre el crecimiento de la producción,
supondrá un leve cambio.
Ese leve cambio puede tener consecuencias enormes.
Entonces África seguirá siendo un importador neto de calorías,
nuevamente impulsado por el crecimiento demográfico y el económico.
Esto suponiendo hipótesis optimistas de crecimiento de la producción.
Entonces en China,
donde la población se está aplanando,
el consumo de calorías explotará
porque los tipos de calorías consumidas
también están empezando a ser alimentos de mayor contenido calórico.
Y, por lo tanto,
estas tres regiones combinadas
comienzan a presentar un desafío realmente interesante para el mundo.
Hasta ahora, los países con déficit calórico
han podido hacer frente a estos déficits
importando de las regiones con excedentes.
Por regiones excedentes, me refiero
a América del Norte, América del Sur y Europa.
Este gráfico de líneas muestra aquí
el crecimiento y el crecimiento previsto para la próxima década
desde América del Norte, América del Sur y Europa.
Lo que no muestra
es que la mayor parte de este crecimiento realmente vendrá de América del Sur.
Y la mayor parte de este crecimiento
será a costa de una enorme deforestación.
Y así, al ver el aumento combinado de la demanda
procedente de India, China y el continente africano,
en comparación con el aumento combinado de la producción
procedente de India, China, el continente africano,
América del Norte, América del Sur y Europa,
se queda con un déficit de 214 billones de calorías,
uno que no podemos producir.
Y esto, suponiendo que se toman todas las calorías excedentes
producidas en América del Norte, América del Sur y Europa
y se exportan únicamente a India, China y África.
Lo que acabo de presentarles es una visión de un mundo imposible.
Podemos hacer algo para cambiar eso.
Podemos cambiar los patrones de consumo,
podemos reducir el desperdicio de alimentos,
o podemos hacer un compromiso audaz
de aumentar exponencialmente las cosechas.
No entraré en el debate
de cambiar los patrones de consumo o de reducir los residuos de alimentos,
porque esos debates ocurren desde hace algún tiempo.
No pasó nada.
Nada ha sucedido porque esos argumentos
de pedir a las regiones excedentarias que cambien su comportamiento
en nombre de las regiones deficitarias,
esperando que otros cambien su comportamiento
en su nombre, para su supervivencia,
es una idea terrible.
Es improductivo.
Así que deseo sugerir una alternativa que viene de las regiones rojas.
China, India, África.
China está restringida en términos de cuánta más tierra disponible
tiene para la agricultura.
Además, tiene enormes problemas de disponibilidad de recursos hídricos.
Así que la respuesta se encuentra realmente en India y en África.
India tiene algo de alza en términos de aumento potencial de cosechas.
Ahora bien, esta es la diferencia entre sus cosechas actuales
y el máximo teórico que puede alcanzar.
Tiene alguna tierra cultivable sin explotar, pero no mucha,
India está bastante restringida.
Ahora bien, el continente africano, por otro lado,
tiene grandes cantidades de tierra cultivable sin explotar
y un significativo potencial alcista en sus cosechas.
En esta imagen algo simplificada aquí,
pero si nos fijamos en las cosechas de África subsahariana en el maíz de hoy,
son donde estaban las cosechas norteamericanos en 1940.
No tenemos 70 años o más para entender esto,
así que significa que necesitamos intentar algo nuevo
y tenemos que probar algo diferente.
La solución comienza con las reformas.
Necesitamos reformar y comercializar
las industrias agrícolas en África
y en India.
En cuanto a la comercialización,
la comercialización no trata solo sobre la agricultura comercial.
La comercialización consiste en aprovechar los datos
para elaborar mejores políticas,
para mejorar la infraestructura,
reducir los costos de transporte
y para reformar completamente las industrias bancarias y de seguros.
La comercialización tiene que ver con llevar la agricultura
desde un esfuerzo demasiado arriesgado hasta uno donde se pueden hacer fortunas.
La comercialización no es una cuestión solo de agricultores.
La comercialización tiene que ver con todo el sistema agrícola.
Pero la comercialización también significa confrontar el hecho
de que ya no podemos colocar la carga del crecimiento
solo en los pequeños agricultores.
Y aceptar que las granjas comerciales y la introducción de granjas comerciales
podrían proporcionar ciertas economías de escala
que incluso los pequeños agricultores pueden aprovechar.
No se trata de la agricultura a pequeña escala o de la agricultura comercial,
o de gran agricultura.
Podemos crear los primeros modelos exitosos de convivencia y éxito
de la pequeña agricultura junto con la agricultura comercial.
Esto se debe a que, por primera vez,
la herramienta más crucial para el éxito en la industria,
los datos y los conocimientos,
se están abaratando día a día.
Y muy pronto, no importará cuánto dinero tengan
o lo grande que sean
para tomar decisiones óptimas y así maximizar la probabilidad de éxito
para alcanzar su meta.
Empresas como Gro trabajan arduamente para hacer de esto una realidad.
Así que si nos comprometemos con esta nueva y audaz iniciativa,
a este nuevo y audaz cambio,
no solo podemos resolver la diferencia de 214 billones de la que hablé,
sino realmente podemos poner al mundo en un camino completamente nuevo.
India puede seguir siendo autosuficiente en alimentos
y África puede emerger como la próxima región azul oscura del mundo.
La nueva pregunta es:
¿Cómo producimos 214 billones de calorías
para alimentar a 8300 millones de personas en 2027?
Tenemos la solución.
Solo tenemos que actuar en consecuencia.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)